on se retrouve dans une situation
d'urgence absolue des prévisions météo
indiquent une détérioration
significative du climat
pas du tout
c'est
[Applaudissements]
quel
est le député qui vient de prononcer
cette phrase
pardon
voilà alors ça a été la séquence du jour
c'est incroyable ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui et c'est vrai que Carlos
Martins binongo on se met à sa place et
on se dit c'est pas possible d'entendre
ça aujourd'hui dans cette affaire le
plus important et le contexte en effet
au moment de cette séquence le député la
France insoumise parler de la situation
des migrants bloqués dans la
Méditerranée ce serait donc deux
apparemment seraient la la version du
député qui a dit ça il dirait que ce
sont deux qui parlaient regardez vous
vous saisir de la question de la
répartition des migrants avec et
d'autres pays européens comme Malte qui
ne répond plus aux demandes de
candidation de sauvetage les personnes
secourues se trouvent dans une situation
d'urgence absolue des prévisions météo
indiquent une décoration significative
du climat
pas du tout
alors face à cette séquence bien entendu
qui a immédiatement fait réagir toute
l'assemblée la séance a été suspendue
regardez
compte tenu de l'émotion légitime qui
s'est emparée de l'ensemble des membres
de assemblée de l'ensemble du
gouvernement de suspendre
l'accessibilité la séance de questions
au gouvernement et nous nous
retrouverons demain la séance est
suspense suspendue
alors le député RN qui a crié c'est
Grégoire de fondas on va essayer de
l'avoir demain parce qu'on va voir les
deux versions il a tenu à s'expliquer
immédiatement au micro de BFM pour lui
il parlait évidemment des migrants
illégaux regarde ce qui s'est passé
c'est que nos collègues de la France
insoumise posé une question sur le
bateau SOS SOS Méditerranée et il
parlait des difficultés qui avaient ce
port à pouvoir accoster en Europe et
j'ai répondu qu'il retourne en Afrique
et cette cette phrase a été détournée
par la France insoumise ils ont compris
ce que moi j'ai eu moi-même du mal à
réaliser que je parlais du député
lui-même ce qui était évidemment
totalement faux on est là dans une
manipulation dans la France insoumise à
la à l'habitude c'est à dire de déformer
les propos des adversaires pour les
diaboliser alors on va revenir là-dessus
dans un instant mais c'est vrai que même
la première ministre Elisabeth borde a
immédiatement réagi le président de la
République a réagi il a quelques
instants je vais vous donner sa réaction
tout le monde réagit c'est un buzz
incroyable malheureusement
regardez ce qu'a dit le Premier ministre
du gouvernement je tiens à le dire le
racisme n'a pas sa place dans notre
démocratie le bureau de l'assemblée se
réunira et naturellement on devra
prendre des sanctions qui savent je
pense que la gravité mérite des censions
exemplaires
alors on va revenir sur Grégoire de
Fournas donc le député RN qui aurait
crié ça à ses yeux comme ils le disent
au contraire la France insoumise qui a
l'esprit mal tourné et ils seront avec
nous dans un instant dont le député bien
entendu Carlos Martin ce bilongo
qu'à la semaine nationale j'allais me
faire insulter en m'insulter moi et
toutes les personnes qui sont en France
ils ont des couleurs de peau et c'est
tellement triste d'arriver à être en
novembre depuis quatre mois nous soyons
ici et on voit la vraie phase de
rassemblement national c'est honteux
c'est complètement honteux d'être envoyé
à sa couleur de peau aujourd'hui et de
voir que le président du groupe de
rassemblement national ne demande pas à
la personne qui a préféré s'insultes de
quitter les mystiques c'est honteux
merci Carlos Martins Villongo d'être
avec nous merci beaucoup merci également
à David Guiron merci d'être là David et
merci Mathilde panot député tous les
trois de la France insoumise on va voir
la séquence j'ai l'impression que moi au
départ c'est vrai que Carlos vous
comprenez pas trop ce que vous êtes dans
votre discours j'ai l'impression
regardez vous allez me dire ce qui s'est
passé parce que c'est vrai que cette
séquence moi je me suis passé repassé et
c'est vrai que c'est incroyable regarde
et vous vous saisir de la question de la
répartition des migrants avec les autres
pays européens comme Malte qui ne répond
plus aux demandes de candidation de
sauvetage les personnes secourues se
trouvent dans une situation d'urgence
absolue les prévisions météo indiquent
une détérioration significative du
climat
pas du tout
alors
je vous sens déjà
je vous sens meurtri par contre je suis
forcément je suis très meurtri parce que
c'est une situation grave j'aurais pas
voulu être là moi on comprend pas
plaisir d'être là je suis député de la
nation je suis un jeune de 31 ans je
suis né à villiers-le-belge je suis né
en France et on me renvoie à ma couleur
de peau
j'ai gagné une belle élection j'ai une
belle circonscription avec des habitants
qui sont magnifiques
et de se faire arrêter vous savez se
poser une question sur SOS Méditerranée
qui est en train de secourir des
personnes en pleine mer
et on m'arrête et on me dit autant en
Afrique et vraiment ce que vous avez
entendu parce que derrière c'est
vraiment ce que c'est vraiment ce que
j'entends et dans tous les regards dans
les jours à venir dans les jours à venir
il va y avoir l'extraction de la vidéo
et des audio ouais vous constaterez et
même là si on réécoute vous pouvez le
remettre s'il vous plaît parce que ils
disent qu'il retourne parler des
migrants pluriel voilà au pluriel
et vous vous saisir de la question de la
répartition des migrants avec d'autres
pays européens comme Malte qui ne répond
plus aux demandes de coordination de
sauvetage les personnes secourues se
trouvent dans une situation d'urgence
absolue des prévisions météo indiquent
une détérioration significative du
climat
pas du tout alors
c'est pas pour vous et c'est
vous avez entendu vous avez pas fait ça
pour vous avez pas fait ce métier pour
entendre ça bien entendu c'est entendu
et ça renvoie à quoi en fait et on a
même des députés de
républicains qui sont juste à quelques
sièges
des députés du rassemblement national
qui ont entendu la même chose moi je
salue la réaction des députés de
l'ensemble de l'hémicycle on a eu des
réactions de des républicains jusqu'au
communiste nous France insoumise
Renaissance la majorité présidentielle
qui ont réagi qui ont fait bloc
ont des propos racistes aujourd'hui en
2022 dans un hémicycle
qu'est-ce que vous auriez à dire à
Grégoire de Fournas qui serait celui qui
aurait dit quoi
moi j'ai rien à lui dire dans le sens où
aujourd'hui son propos parce que lui il
dit qu'il parlait des migrants voilà qui
fusée c'est encore des propos racistes
même si il parle de migrants qui sont
plein de merde aujourd'hui il a insulté
un député de la République français
et il insulte des millions de Français
derrière
moi ce matin j'ai invité des amis et des
enfants de ma circonscription à
l'Assemblée
j'ai montré ma question j'ai dit
aujourd'hui monsieur bilongo
l'enseignant je suis enseignant à Paris
sur quoi l'économie la gestion d'accords
il y a plein de personnes qui
aujourd'hui qui c'est un site là ils
apprennent pour eux cette triste de de
tout ça en 2022
pas en 2022
si on laisse passer ça cela va être quoi
demain
c'est incroyable de toute façon je crois
que c'est devenu d'être envoyé à sa
couleur de peau non mais là c'est c'est
en France non l'Afrique j'ai été une
semaine en vacances je ne connais même
pas les 31 ans j'ai 31 ans incroyable
d'être député à 31 ans c'est une énorme
fierté pour vous certainement aux
parents pour votre famille pour vos
élèves et là
qu'est-ce que vous dites aux gens qui
qui disent
ils récupèrent ce qu'on va en parler
avec Mathilde et David la France
insoumise récupère ça des fins
politiques pour se victimiser qu'est-ce
que vous leur avez les propos c'est pas
la France insoumise c'est les
républicains Renaissance modernes tous
les partis politiques qui étaient
présents dans les musiques
et qui sont sincères dans leur démarche
on fait
aujourd'hui si on a rassemblement
national avec leur président Sébastien
Chenu qui refuse qui dit que non ils
n'ont pas dit ça c'est juste que eux ils
sont corporatifs ils sont juste
corporate
vous avez les images rassemblées c'est
des députés de différentes possibilités
qui sont là c'est inacceptable en 2022
inacceptable c'est parce que je suis
député est-ce que on va voir un employé
du service une femme de ménage inquiétée
ça dérange pas mais dès lors où on est
député ça dérange et je me demande si
cette question là si importante je vous
dis une réponse moi de la ministre par
rapport à SOS Méditerranée j'ai discuté
moi avec la sens Méditerranée toute la
journée pour avoir la tendance il avait
ça fait 11 jours qui sont en mer et j'ai
pas eu de réponse et ma question c'était
pas terminée
est-ce que si c'était mon collègue avait
posé cette question ma collègue est-ce
que elle repère est au bout de cette
question on se demande mais c'est des
millions de Français qui sont blessés
des millions de Français qui sont
blessés et aujourd'hui c'est le français
là ils sont devant votre chaîne il veut
une réponse moi aussi je veux une
réponse à la hauteur des choses on
espère qu'on aura une réponse on a lancé
Mathilde panneau vous étiez bien sûr
présente vous avez entendu comme comme
nous l'a dit Carlos c'est un instant
quelques pas qu'est-ce que vous avez
l'air aussi les trois là vous avez l'air
extrêmement triste extrêmement choquée
par ce qui s'est passé qu'est-ce que
vous répondez Mathilde et David ce que
je disais à Carlos il y a un instant à
ceux qui disent vous en faites trop
c'est de la récupération qu'est-ce que
vous leur dites NON enfin on ne laisse
pas passer quelque chose qui est
inadmissible dans la société qui est un
délit je le rappelle et qui n'est pas un
dérapage raciste de la part du
rassemblement national qui est une
injure raciste qui correspond à leur ADN
politique le rassemblement national n'a
jamais cessé d'être raciste et si nous
sommes aussi inquiets du fait qu'il y
ait 89 députés à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est notamment parce que il porte en
eux un poison de la haine et de la
division du peuple qui est insupportable
moi je suis là d'abord comme présidente
de groupe en soutien et en solidarité à
Carlos je n'accepte pas je ne laisserai
jamais passer le fait qu'on renvoie un
des députés qui portent de nombreux
communs combats à sa couleur de peau
vous êtes donc nous allons demander une
sanction ça fait de quoi la sanction la
sanction la plus haute qui existe dans
le règlement de l'Assemblée une sanction
qui interdit physiquement à un député de
venir à l'Assemblée nationale pendant 15
jours et qui ensuite pendant deux mois
lui enlève la moitié de son indemnité
elle a été utilisée seulement une fois
depuis 1958 c'est ce que nous demandons
et demain aura lieu un bureau
exceptionnel sur cette question une
espèce d'enquête c'est ça où ils vont
réécouter ce que nous disait Carlos pour
voir vraiment ce qui a été dit ou pas et
puis on verra ce que demande les
différents groupes politiques mais quand
Carlos Martin bilongo vous explique que
de jusqu'au LR jusqu'à la France
insoumise et les communistes l'ensemble
de l'assemblée a entendu retourne en
Afrique et scandalisé à juste titre
parce qu'il s'est passé je pense que on
aura cette sanction sans mal qui est en
deuxième chose
c'est possible ça ou pas possible on
peut pas demander à une démission donc
on verra ce que vous avez dit donc 15
jours qui est prévue par l'Assemblée
c'est ça qu'un jour de mise à pied plus
derrière
d'indemnité pendant la moitié de
l'indemnité pendant 2 mois c'est la plus
grosse sanction qui existe aujourd'hui
mais moi je voudrais dire quand même une
deuxième chose en tant que président de
groupe
mon groupe parlementaire Daniel au Bono
qui a été vous vous en rappelez des
peintres comme en esclave dans le
journal valeur actuelle elle a gagné son
procès contre valeur actuelle Daniel
obono est celle qui dans la précédente
mandature a le plus siéger dans
l'hémicycle Carlos est celui qui siège
je crois le plus de notre groupe dans
l'hémicycle c'est celui qui va nous
représenter à la COP 27 excusez-nous
c'est quand même quelque chose
d'extrêmement important c'est juste
l'enjeu numéro un de savoir si on garde
un écosystème qui est compatible avec la
vie humaine Carlos est un spécialiste du
monde associatif il travaille sur le
monde associatif il vient de faire une
proposition de loi qui va l'amener à
aller ce weekend rencontrer le parlement
algérien j'aimerais qu'on puisse parler
du travail que font ces députés et non
que ça soit pour Daniel au Bono que ça
soit pour Carlos Martens belongo on les
renvoie constamment à leur couleur de
peau en 2022 c'est intolérable
intolérable et on ne laissera pas ça
passer
d'abord je vous écoute monsieur
effectivement je comprends votre rage
votre colère votre et moi parce
qu'effectivement moi quand j'ai vu la
séquence j'ai trouvé ça très choquant et
absolument insupportable
après je je suis très gênée parce qu'en
fait je comprends qu'il y a une sorte de
cohésion et solidarité au niveau de
l'Assemblée nationale où tout le monde a
entendu ça mais malgré tout moi je
n'entends pas ça donc je suis très alors
plus rien alors je vous le dis je vous
dis
en tout cas sur les réseaux sociaux de
ce que les gens qui réagissent je vous
le dit Mathilde voilà je vous dis à
David aussi à Carlos moi je le fais
juste rapporter beaucoup de gens disent
ils parlaient les migrants apparemment
il parlait il était il au pluriel alors
moi je voulais que je vous dise alors
c'est c'est dramatique aussi mais je
préférais parce que je voilà Carlos moi
je me mets je me mets à la place de
Carlos et je me mets à la place de la
famille de Carlos et franchement
je me dis si ce qui a été dit et ce que
nous dit Carlos qui me ressemblent bien
sûr non mais même moi je me mets
français
mettez-vous à la place des Français tous
les matins se révèlent à 4h du matin 3h
du matin est-ce qu'ils sont contents
d'avoir un député mais oui qui monte au
créneau moi je suis la question et
aujourd'hui moi je suis fier d'avoir un
député de 31 ans déjà je trouve ça
énorme c'est incroyable c'est avant tout
ça c'est c'est une réussite incroyable
c'est moi je voilà je vous dis c'est
incroyable un député de 31 ans déjà
c'est c'est fou normalement c'est déjà
une réussite incroyable mais oui David
il y a il y a quelque chose
d'incontestable c'est que quand la
phrase elle a été prononcée tout le
monde s'est levé c'est pas des blagues
il y en a il y en a un j'ai vu balano
lrem le type on arrête pas de se crier
dessus on a mis ici qu'on enfin c'est
des gens avec des images on les a oui il
s'est levé c'était c'était hyper
physique je veux dire tout tout le monde
a compris le même truc et après moi je
alors on va regarder on en revanche
attendez juste vas-y vas-y David vas-y
je sais pas comment vous entendez un
pluriel sur cette phrase il y en a pas
c'est pas possible qu'ils prennent ou
qui avec un esprit avec les migrants en
fait souvent on a l'impression
vous savez pourquoi je vous dis ça parce
que quand je l'ai entendu je me suis dit
moi-même et aussi on a tous ce réflexe
un peu c'est pas possible c'est
tellement il a il a dû vouloir dire
autre chose je vous jure que c'était ma
première réaction c'est pas possible il
y a pas de dire ça mais en fait en
vérité quand vous regardez je sais même
pas ce qu'on va donner le compte-rendu
de séance mais quand vous regardez ce
qui s'est passé à l'intérieur de
l'hémicycle je vous assure que la
première réaction de tout le monde ça a
été de se lever et dire il a il a
vraiment dit ça donc on a presque pas
envie d'y croire mais c'est ce qui a été
dit et ça je pense que vous voyez c'est
pas quelque chose qui est contestable et
moi ce qui m'énerve encore plus dedans
c'est ce qu'a dit Mathilde c'est que
Carlos je le connaissais pas avant c'est
un ami oh on est devenu amis puisqu'on
se fréquente etc et je le vois je vous
jure Carlos c'est un de ceux qui a le
plus souvent sur des bancs de
l'Assemblée même à 2h du mat etc et
c'est tellement rageant de se dire que
avec tout le travail qui fait la
première fois où médiatiquement il
apparaît sur le devant de la scène etc
c'est parce qu'il est ramené à ça
il voulait pas venir pour ça
que si c'est le cas moi ce qui est venu
un tout petit peu c'est que pour
l'instant juste quelque chose qui n'a
pas été jugé et ce qui m'ennuie c'est
que moi pareil comme Géraldine ou alors
je suis fou j'entends qui parle la
situation des migrants est horrible mais
j'entends qu'il retourne en Afrique les
migrants et tant qu'on est pas sûr que
ça s'adressait monsieur je trouve que là
il y a une petite récupération politique
quelque chose
si c'est le cas c'est ignoble pour
Monsieur et vous le dire si c'est pas le
cas on est en train de faire mais alors
voilà je vous répondre
si c'est pas le cas ça veut dire qu'il y
a un type quand même qui est en pleine
hémicycle oui déclare à propos de gens
qui sont en train de mourir c'est pas
pareil
il est en train de dire que les migrants
qui viennent et qui peuvent mourir vaut
mieux qu'ils retournent en Afrique on
peut avoir plein de débats sur
l'immigration mais désolé le discours
que j'entends c'est qu'en gros pardon je
parlais pas du bon noir quoi non c'est
pas possible
on n'est pas d'accord avec ça pareil
députés on n'a jamais des contraires
mais pour l'instant il y a aucune aucune
preuve qui disent que pour l'instant
qu'il retourne en Afrique ça s'adresse à
Monsieur donc si c'est le cas c'est
horrible
demain il y a un bureau qui se réunit
une extraction aujourd'hui donc
mais pour le moment je trouve que pour
l'instant tant qu'on a pas la pour
l'instant c'est la récupération
politique pas du tout pas du tout pas du
tout on va revoir la séquence que ce que
nous disait David c'est que tous les
députés sont levés un moment regardez
regardez et personne secourue se trouve
dans une situation d'urgence absolue les
prévisions météo indiquent une
détérioration significative du climat
pas du tout
c'est
[Applaudissements]
quel est le député qui vient de
prononcer cette phrase
je vous propose compte tenu de l'émotion
légitime qui s'est emparée de l'ensemble
des membres de assemblée de l'ensemble
du gouvernement de suspendre la séance
de questions au gouvernement et nous
nous retrouverons demain la séance est
suspendus
oui Carlos moi je vais vous poser une
question en 2017 il y a un tweet de
Grégoire de Fournas donc le député en
question qui avait dit en Afrique ils
aiment tous la France et ses allocs on
accueille toute l'Afrique point
d'interrogation ce qui sous-tend quand
même que peut-être quand il dit qu'il
retourne il y a un s à qui le retourne
et ce qui s'adresse pas à tous les
Africains alors je vous dis pas que
c'est mieux
mais non c'est pas mieux
que de s'adresser à vous en tant que
quelque chose parce que moi j'avais une
j'avais obtenu une sanction sur un
député la République en marche qui
m'avait insulté de poissonnière alors
que je montais à la tribune on entendait
très distinctement dans la vidéo très
distinctement et pourtant ça n'avait pas
ça n'avait pas été noté au compte rendu
vous savez il y a des gens qui en bas de
la tribune note tout ce qu'ils entendent
dans l'hémicycle qui sont normalement
bien placés pour pouvoir l'entendre ça
n'avait pas été noté au compte-rendu et
donc on me refusait la sanction à ce
titre là puisque ça n'avait pas été noté
j'ai gagné sur cette question là et vous
verrez que si nous avons tous cette
réaction c'est non seulement parce que
nous avons tous entendu retourne en
Afrique et que en plus de ça vous avez
un député RN qui ne cache même pas son
vrai visage et qui ment sur ce qu'il a
dit et qui en plus utilisent dans son
mensonge une autre phrase raciste ce qui
était en train de poser comme question
Carlos comme c'est Grégoire
il était en train de poser une question
sur la question de situation de gens qui
sont en mer je rappelle qu'il y a un
droit de la mère qui existe qui oblige à
porter secours à des gens quel que soit
leur nationalité leur couleur de peau
leur religion je ne sais quoi c'est
juste un droit de la mère qui est un
droit international et Carlos était en
train d'expliquer au moment où il a été
interrompu que il y avait des conditions
météorologiques qui étaient extrêmes
dans les prochains jours et que donc la
question qui allait se poser c'est de
savoir si ces femmes enceintes ses
enfants ces gens qui sont complètement
épuisés sur ce bateau qui sont là depuis
11 jours vont pouvoir survivre ou pas
donc dans tous les cas
oui bien sûr on comprend moi c'est
horrible voilà quoi qu'il arrive mais
c'est vrai que c'est c'est pas c'est pas
c'est justement ça le problème on peut
avoir tous les débats qu'on veut sur
l'immigration mais dire ça à ce
moment-là mais à quel moment dans ce
pays on s'habitue à ce point-là c'est
devenu tellement banal en fait qu'on se
dise à propos de gens qui sont en train
de mourir
est très mauvaise il vaut mieux qu'il
retourne en Afrique
quand vous présentez la chose on dirait
qu'il était prêt à leur servir les
croissants et le café mais non non c'est
pas comme ça qu'il l'a dit il l'a dit
d'une manière extrêmement violente il a
dit retourne en Afrique et je le redis
je le répète quand vous avez toute
l'assemblée nationale je veux dire il y
a des gens de Courson enfin je sais pas
s'il était je crois que je l'ai vu en
bas mais mais bah là non c'est des gens
avec qui on s'engueule en permanence
hein c'est pas nos alliés politiques
donc quand tout le monde se lève moi je
ne sais même pas ce qu'il va y avoir
dans le compte-rendu du sens mais quand
tout le monde se lève je vous assure que
ça veut dire quelque chose et il y a des
gens y compris des députés même parfois
de la même de droite le patron du groupe
les républicains tweets aussi avec la
citation retourne en Afrique le patron
du groupe il est à côté d'eux hein nous
on est de l'autre côté mais les
républicains présidents de la République
aussi qui a qui est extrêmement choqué
il a un jeu auprès de de personnes voilà
il a réussi il y a quelques instants il
était extrêmement choqué si c'est le cas
si c'est le cas voilà alors juste
Grégoire de Fournas il vous a écrit il
vous a écrit
Grégoire de fondas il a il a écrit aucun
cas mais propos ne vous était destinés
voilà je n'aurais jamais prononcé ni
tolérer une quelconque déclaration
raciste ou une insulte à votre égard
quand il écrit ça Carlos comme on vous
le prenez
c'est propos là je n'ai pas besoin en
fait mais pourquoi vous le croyez pas
où est-ce que je le crois moi c'est au
moment où ce qui m'a fait la question je
veux je suis arrêté moi sur une question
importante et je vous le dis et on aura
le résultat demain ou après demain
retourne en Afrique
et si les résultats est négatifs
je sais pas si vous vous rendez compte
de ce que vous êtes en train
15 députés
nous avons quatre questions gouvernement
par semaine que nous choisissons
soigneusement
Carlos c'était sa première question au
gouvernement d'accord sa première
question gouvernement sur lequel il n'y
a pas eu de réponse du gouvernement et
sur lequel il a dû s'interrompre
en fait quand vous parlez de
récupération politique pourquoi c'est un
digne de dire ça c'est pas parce que non
non
mais que je considère grave quand même
par exemple une députée de la République
en marche qui le mandat précédent alors
qu'elle était en train de parler dans
l'hémicycle quelqu'un un député a jugé
bon de bêler pendant qu'elle parlait je
l'ai défendu Carlos ne serait pas de mon
groupe je l'aurai défendu parce que ce
n'est pas acceptable il faut imaginer ce
que ça veut dire pour des millions de
gens dans ce pays qui subissent du
racisme
pour le moment
tu as raison et si le comité dit
l'inverse ce n'est donc pas de valeur
petite vie mais sachez que des millions
de Français aujourd'hui à l'heure où
vous parlez là ce centre blessé parce
que c'est un c'est des propos racistes
si c'est le cas c'est des propos
racistes et ça renvoie un député à sa
couleur de peau ça renvoie des millions
de Français à leur couleur de peau
maintenant
48 heures tant pis pour vous mais
aujourd'hui à la minute ou pas des
millions de Français sont blessés moi
en tout cas voilà moi si vous voulez
attendre des 48 heures attendez 24
heures pour réagir je vous saurais pas
grave je me sens extrêmement blessé
Carlos et c'est Noël sachez-le pour moi
il faut que vous passiez autre chose il
devient être vous devriez être fier vous
êtes député à 31 ans incroyable c'est
une carrière incroyable
non j'ai fait ma campagne électorale
j'ai des milliers j'ai gagné peu importe
mon âge non non mais je vous dis moi je
vous le dis je veux je veux être en
voyage rien du tout juste mais vous le
dis moi je vous le dis je suis très
belle réussite je vous le dis je suis
député de la nation française je suis né
habiller le Bel j'habite à
Villiers-le-Bel et je suis fier d'être
français
c'est tout simplement la démocratie que
vous preniez la tête avec ça
exactement
de pauvres en France il y a des grosses
difficultés financières
des pasteur thermique mais je vous le
dis je vous le dis moi je vous le dis
ici
mais je veux dire aujourd'hui on
débarque pas j'en profite aujourd'hui
parce que je suis pas invités
par rapport à cette phrase que la
médiatique on aimerait bien vous inviter
aujourd'hui bah j'espère que vous allez
revenir pour autre chose j'espère aussi
on est tous arbitra c'est sûr pour autre
chose je vous le dis parce que là
aujourd'hui voilà vous êtes dans l'actu
malheureusement pour ça ce qu'a dit
Mathilde votre première intervention
assemblée vous êtes sous peu des
projecteurs à cause de ça on espère vous
inviter une autre fois pour parler
d'autre sujet par exemple
vous viendrez avec plaisir et puis on
est le seul député de position à y aller
donc ça va Carlo ça va ou pas
vous revenez vous allez revenir nous
voir
pour la cop27 avec plaisir bah voilà
elle va très bien et oubliez arrêtez de
vous prendre la tête avec ça ça me fait
je me prends pas dans la tête avec ça
il y a des millions de Français qui sont
blessés
il y a pas longtemps vous étiez à gaz
pour un tournoi de foot de jeune fille
vous vous rappelez c'était une dernière
bon peut-être que vous vous rappelez pas
mais c'est un événement où les gens vous
ont super accueillis je sais que j'ai
kiffé
un très bon moment aujourd'hui son nom
de fou je me suis régalé voilà voilà
c'est pas votre famille c'est juste des
amis ou des connaissances aujourd'hui
ils sont blessés mais nous aussi on est
blessé de voir ça mais on est tous
blessés on a on a aucun intérêt à mentir
on vous assure on aurait préféré enfin
nous ça nous amuse pas de faire ça et et
et la République en marche la droite le
modem ils ont pas d'intérêt à mentir
nous on était en train de parler de
questions au Gouvernement chacun voulait
avancer ces sujets sociaux même il y en
a qui voulaient parler d'immigration on
veut pas faire ça et même ils ne sont
pas des mentors
merci David merci Carlo et merci
Mathilde il va y avoir à l'enquête
demain on aura des news merci à vous
trois